these are patriots the people like
Murray Ivanovitch here's an honorable
patriotic American Jovanovic who risked
everything had nothing to gain
Ambassador Jovanovic has been a real
hero to her colleagues ambassador
you wanna which what he told new
documents suggest though that
impeachment darling Murray Ivanovich
wasn't completely honest with Congress
when it came to hunter Biden and burries
majani me now with the exclusive details
as John Solomon journalist and Fox News
contributor along with New York
Congressman Lee Zeldin John while
ambassador Jovanovic ambassador to the
Ukraine claimed otherwise you oh she
claimed this you've uncovered that she
knew more about buries men hunter Biden
than she let on tell us yeah absolutely
because of congressman's Eldon's good
question this is what we know she
testified everything she knew about
barrese Manhunter Biden came from a
briefing before she went before the
Senate to be confirmed and from press
reports and and congressman Zeldin kept
repressing you only knew about press
reports she said yeah that's all I
remember it turns out she had meetings
directly with barrese but
representatives she received letters
detailed letters from bracelet
representatives detailing their efforts
to get out from under a criminal
investigation before Donald Trump became
president she didn't mention any of
those and there's only two good options
here right one is she falsely testified
knowing that she had these contacts the
second is she didn't review her
documents before she testified and it
was a proceeding where we were removing
the President of the United States
possibly not a good situation for the
hero of the the hearings now here's what
you voinovich told Congress about the
optics of hunter Biden's job at barrese
mo was that ever you know concern or at
least the perception of that concern
addressed as I said I arrived in August
of 2016 you know several months before
the elections and several months before
President Trump took office and it was
not a focus of what I was doing in that
six month period
congressman Zeldin these new documents
show that she sent a hundred and fifty
pages worth of emails about Purisima
that she was full of it and this is a
woman who was highly regarded as an
intelligent woman she's
Princeton educated she is someone who I
don't believe actually didn't recall
didn't remember when I was pressing her
for additional information beyond the
Press reports what else does she know
about verissimo and zilch F ski and all
we could get back is I don't recall I
just don't buy that I think what you're
essentially seeing is a whitewashing
attempt from that moment she arrives in
August of 2016 to when Vice President
Biden goes to Ukraine in January of 2017
as John Solomon working with citizens
united produced all these different
documents between emails meetings
discussions there's just no way that she
showed up at that impeachment deposition
under oath actually not remembering any
of this John wasn't this important then
that the elites in the media MSNBC folks
at ABC and CNN I mean they lyin eyes
marie ivanovitch i mean she should have
been up on rushmore at the end of what
they were saying it was like vinda minh
colonel vin de man lieutenant colonel
vin minh and marie ivanovich and all the
other cast of characters who were
clearly very displeased with with
President Trump that at the bottom at
the bottom of all this yeah listen right
now they're building a new mountain it's
called Mount shift and there's going to
be people like Christopher Steele and
Murray Ivanovich on the face of that
mountain what we have our group of
witnesses who gave us a false narrative
and it takes months after Adam Schiff
presents his evidence for we and the
media to get the truth to dig it out
everything about the ship show is
falling apart whether it's Russia or
Ukraine I expect a lot of big
revelations coming up in Ukraine in the
next few weeks Senator Ron Johnson
tonight announced he's going to issue a
subpoena to the very group that met with
Ivanovich to talk about burry smih in
December of 2016 that's a major new
development I mean it's hard sometimes
for regular folks out there congressman
Zeldin to keep this Venn diagram of you
know lies deception and unfair
persecution of people that has taken
place over the last really four or five
years but we're now beginning to see it
we're now beginning to see it Americans
are seeing the double standard they know
that if Murray ivanovitch
was there to remove President Barack
Obama from office that you would have
many of these same mainstream media
outlets calling for there to be a
perjury investigation internally but
instead they'll fact check all this and
claim that nothing that she said was
dishonest protecting clapper and we're
seeing with power and all these others
and Schiff was mentioned exactly analyst
gentlemen who actually dug other than
john psalm and a few others gentlemen
thank you